Well, greets you from Cristian Cásseres with his
brief news report in Spanish.
Raiders coach Jiangling
resigned after several
controversial emails following an investigation
published by the New York Times. He
resigned saying he doesn't want to be a
distraction for the team and  He
thanked all the staff, the
employees and even the team's supporters, he
ended his message by saying I
'm sorry I never wanted to hurt anyone
after Cruzen's resignation the team
said that the new coach for the
moment will be empty reich he is 61
years old he hasn't  Lots of experience
coaching a team however will
replace the club while they
find someone permanent
One person has died after being
struck by a vehicle on
Tropicana stone fences The Metropolitan Police
said this happened
before 4am on
Tuesday  when the person tried to
cross the street this case is still under
investigation
and the strong  gusty winds caused
connection problems around the
valley north las vegas i can
see it was without power for several hours i take
it you are saying that more than 11,000
people suffered power outages while
the winds reached 60 miles per
hour most of those affected already
count  with your electric service
and we will continue with some winds
for today there is a wind alert
that runs until 5 pm this
will make it feel much cooler in
fact 4 inches of snow reported
in mauthausen now speaking the
temperatures can see there that the
weekend we will reach almost 80
degrees I am Cristian Cáceres with super
informative news now in Spanish good
day
[Music]